Quand on vit de l'agriculture,
on ne compte pas ses heures,
en particulier quand on s'occupe
d'animaux. Pour faire en sorte
que le métier soit moins
accaparant et pallier,
du même coup, la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre en agriculture,
de nouveaux modèles commencent
à émerger. Voici l'exemple
d'un producteur laitier au
Lac-Saint-Jean, qui est en
quête d'un meilleur équilibre
entre travail et loisirs.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narratrice): Guillaume
Paradis a l'âme d'un aventurier.
Ce grand amateur de plein air et
de voyages a déjà mené une vie
de nomade. Puis, il a effectué
un retour à la terre.
Son métier le passionne, mais
il est accaparant. Aujourd'hui,
à l'aube de la quarantaine, il
aspire à davantage de liberté.
- Je veux pas que le travail
prenne toute la place, t'sais,
sur ma situation, sur ma vie.
Je veux m'ouvrir, je veux
me garder la porte ouverte
pour d'autres choses.
- Guillaume est producteur
laitier. En 2016, quand l'heure
de la retraite a sonné pour ses
parents, il n'a pas hésité à
acheter l'entreprise familiale :
la ferme Marlise à Normandin,
au Lac-Saint-Jean.
- J'ai tout le temps considéré
que c'est la plus belle chance
du monde quand même de venir
au monde sur une ferme, sur une
terre. Donc c'est sûr que c'est
quelque chose que je voulais pas
laisser passer.
- Il est propriétaire
d'un troupeau de 115 bêtes,
dont 60 vaches en lactation.
Il possède des terres, des
bâtiments et de l'équipement
agricole. Il a agrandi l'étable
et il a plusieurs projets en
tête. Son père lui donne encore
un bon coup de main et il a un
employé. Mais il travaille tout
de même 80 heures par semaine,
ce qui lui laisse bien peu
de temps libre.
- J'ai 4 heures par jour à moi.
Je peux pas aller plus loin que
2 heures par là parce qu'au bout
du 2 heures, il faut que je
revienne pour faire mes vaches,
t'sais, là.
♪ ♪ ♪
Quand même je ferais des
centaines de milliers de dollars
par année, là, en salaire,
qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je fasse avec? C'est ça,
dans le fond.
- Il a tenté de recruter
des employés. Or, le taux de
roulement est élevé et, souvent,
les bons employés veulent gérer
leur propre entreprise.
Pour Guillaume, le constat
s'est vite imposé.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les gens, ils veulent un
pouvoir de décision. Les gens,
ils veulent un sentiment
d'appartenance, t'sais.
Puis les gens, ils veulent
être rémunérés à la hauteur
de ce qu'ils rapportent sur
l'entreprise. Ça fait que c'est
tout ça que j'ai mis ensemble,
puis c'est comme ça que j'ai
créé mon modèle, dans le fond.
- Voici son modèle, son rêve :
l'entreprise agricole bâtie par
ses parents vaut aujourd'hui
environ 3 millions $.
C'est la ferme laitière typique
au Québec. Guillaume veut rester
l'unique propriétaire de la
terre et conserver la valeur
actuelle des bâtiments et
des équipements de la ferme.
Mais il cherche un alter ego,
un partenaire, pour cultiver
les terres et exploiter la ferme
laitière avec lui. Ils se
partageront les revenus de la
ferme et les dépenses futures.
L'avantage pour son éventuel
associé, c'est qu'il n'aura pas
à verser de mise de fonds de
plusieurs centaines de milliers
de dollars pour devenir
copropriétaire.
- Dans le fond, si on veut
réussir à pérenniser ton
modèle...
- L'agroéconomiste Denis
Larouche aide Guillaume à
peaufiner les détails du projet.
- Son principe, c'est de dire :
le fonds de terre, c'est dur
à payer, c'est dur à acheter.
Ça, je vais le garder pour moi.
Puis tout le reste, si quelqu'un
veut s'associer avec moi, on va
faire une photo un moment donné
de ce que je vaux, puis la suite
on va se partager ça 50-50.
- Donc cette personne-là,
à partir de ce jour-là, bien,
on achète une terre demain
matin, bien, la terre qu'on
achète, elle appartient aux
deux, OK? Le quota qu'on achète
de plus appartient aux deux;
le troupeau s'agrandit,
il appartient aux deux.
- Les copropriétaires
rembourseront la dette actuelle
ensemble. La diminution de la
dette fera grimper la valeur de
la ferme. Ils en bénéficieront
tous les deux. Et ils décideront
conjointement du développement
de l'entreprise et des
investissements futurs.
♪ ♪ ♪
Guillaume a prévu une période
d'essai d'un an à salaire avant
de s'engager, pour s'assurer
que son éventuel associé et
lui partagent la même vision.
- Dans le fond, je cherche
le frère que j'ai pas, OK. Parce
que, bon, si j'avais un frère,
je serais associé avec, on se
partagerait les fins de semaine,
comme toute entreprise qui sont
deux frères font en général.
- Le modèle de Guillaume
offre aussi de la souplesse.
Les futurs partenaires
partageront les revenus au
prorata du temps travaillé
pendant l'année. Chaque associé
pourra s'offrir du temps libre.
- Il peut faire un métier.
Il peut faire un voyage,
s'occuper de sa famille.
Puis d'autres moments donnés,
ils sont ensemble. Puis un autre
moment donné, c'est Guillaume
qui quitte puis c'est son
associé qui s'occupe de la
business à ce moment-là.
Donc ça prend quelqu'un qui
a de la responsabilité, qui a
de la graine d'entrepreneur.
- Guillaume devra aussi être
à l'écoute, s'adapter et,
forcément, faire des compromis.
- C'est pas son fils, c'est pas
sa fille. Donc un moment donné,
il va falloir qu'il concède
des choses. Puis si t'as pas
cette concession-là, bien,
tu réussiras pas à atteindre
ton objectif parce que, dans
le fond, tu es un vendeur.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Trouver le partenaire idéal
n'est pas simple. Guillaume
fait donc appel aux services de
L'ARTERRE. Cette organisation
jumelle des aspirants
agriculteurs à des propriétaires
de ferme.
- C'est... je dirais rapide à
la blague : c'est encore pire
qu'un mariage, là. C'est à tous
les jours. Il va falloir que ces
gens-là travaillent ensemble.
Il va falloir qu'ils développent
ensemble.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La perle rare pourra bâtir
sur des bases solides.
La ferme laitière de Guillaume
est rentable. Mais il faut aussi
assurer l'avenir de la ferme
à long terme.
(meuglement)
- Guillaume, mettons qu'il a
pas de relève, puis mettons
que c'est moi, l'associé, puis
j'ai de la relève, bien là,
la difficulté du transfert
va revenir à zéro parce que
le fonds de terre a pas été
transféré. Donc comment on fait
pour pérenniser ça? On peut
penser peut-être à des produits
qui vont grandir, comme des
produits d'assurances, qui
pourraient grandir au même titre
que la valeur du fonds de terre.
- Ce concept de ferme à partager
sort des sentiers battus.
Et il y a des sceptiques
dans le milieu agricole.
- J'ai déjà entendu : «Bah,
t'es pas un vrai agriculteur,
dans le fond, parce que toi,
ce que tu veux, tu veux faire
d'autre chose, t'sais.» Mon
Dieu, t'sais, c'est quasiment...
c'est un peu tabou, là!
- Moi, je peux vous confirmer
que Guillaume, c'est un bon
agriculteur, puis c'est un vrai
agriculteur.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et avec la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et le manque
criant de relève en agriculture,
des partenariats comme celui que
propose Guillaume deviendront
sans doute incontournables.
- Tout change. Les modèles
agricoles changent aussi.
Ça prend un peu de liberté.
Il faut trouver un équilibre
entre le travail et le loisir.
Le projet de Guillaume le
démontre clairement que cet
équilibre-là est atteignable,
puis qu'il est nécessaire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À sa façon, en faisant fi
des tabous, Guillaume Paradis
ouvre la voie à une nouvelle
génération d'agriculteurs.
- Je pars une semaine par été
faire de la descente de rivière
en canot. Je pars, t'sais...
je pars pas, je me sauve,
dans le fond! Je veux juste
être capable de dire : si je
veux partir, je suis capable.
T'sais, c'est toute la
différence. T'sais, là.
♪ ♪ ♪